just flying around out there no way to  finished yeah  and that's gonna do it  all I got to do is let the air out of  the ball actually it's about one second  different shot clock game clocks and  Gordon can yo-yo it  as long as he wants  so after the Rockets lost those four  games now they're going to win six of  the next date and it's a good time to  start another winning streak for the  Houston Rockets  I think they're going to put a few ticks  back on the clock to make it official  18th 40-point game on the year for  Hardin and in that fourth quarter  Houston asked for Charlotte 33 to 22 in  fact they held him to only 47  second-half points take a look at Austin  Rivers he he got that last rebound  instead of James so James did not get  the triple-double is like my bad James  [Music]  Clavell teammate right there yes it is  but he's not happy